on va jouer avec jean marc généreux et
aurait des leçons en apprendre un peu
plus sur eux à y a des chiffres des neuf
mois c'est parti leila les déchiffrer
les
je t'aime et jean marc généreux des
chiffres sur vous n'êtes pas normal ça
veut dire des gens sympas il vient du
latin malus exact on va des chiffres 16
et vous jouez chez vous bien entendu on
sait que vous aimez ce jeu c'est le nom
de son album où c'est son âge où c'est
les deux à la solidarité qui travaillent
mais nathalie bien sûr qu'ils partent
tout de suite en soir orientale juste
après quand elle vient et parents sont
exactement moi je vous connaissiez ou
hdmi oui et c'est tout ma fille a envoyé
lé elle a dit maman la chance que tu as
tu vas l'avoir et vos premiers tp mais
c'est top elle embrasse elle vous allez
voir
moi ma fille qui à 52 ans elle m'a dit
wak tout premier album 16 qui sortira à
00h tu es très bien tu m'avais promis je
serai là le jour de la sortie de la
machine à et voilà tu me fait des
promesses étaient là je suis comme un
putsch suis très content au mariage avec
michou de koné michaud aussi
alors c'est forcément être un carton
c'est sait où ce qui se passe autour de
toi un coin c'est incroyable c'est le
nombre de fans que tu as sur les réseaux
sur les plateformes le succès incroyable
anissa ça a été un truc de fou derrière
on pouvait croire mine de rien c'est du
moins la faire un tube derrière coco et
encore plus un carton c'est que c'est
vrai mais moi tu vois je sais plus
lequel préfet entre coco et annie 100g
pas dénigrer même ça mais je préfère
coco bah ouais c'est vrai mais c'est
qu'alors tu me suis dis la vérité je
crois que moi aussi on dégustera nous ça
oui mais j'ai fait le rôle où j'ai dit
non au motion ça j'en vois pourquoi ce
qui ferait cocon puis commence à écouter
une fois deux fois trois fois way et
après je suis qu'au cours de ce débat
c'est parce qu'un visage et les trois
critères
ouais mais c'est sympa aussi quand même
un problème pour les deux cas carrière
je me bats c'est vrai on a le cul d'un
conte koulouba merci patron on a la
musique pas je sais qu'on a la musique
on la met tous les jours
[Rires]
pourquoi mais on a quand même une exclu
nouveau titre de wesley
[Musique]
et on a la même une deuxième n'y a que
nous qui l'avons
[Applaudissements]
la borne d'âge des 16 vous i way the
dance est une star quand elle arrive sur
un plateau il se passe quelque chose
jean-marc se réveille toi qui connais et
truc tu trouves pas que c est là l un
truc spécial et les salaires on voit que
cette jeune demoiselle elle est solide
sur ses patins a du charisme
non mais elle a du caractère mais elle
est gentille des halles est ouverte
on peut parler elle a un regard super
gens si jamais elle à elle a un truc tu
as un truc en plus c'est gentil les
chéris c'est là une question oui je sais
pas pourquoi vous savez pas si on a le
clip de coco vous préparez pas
l'émission en amont
dire quelque chose jean bienvenue au
club vous voulez un truc qui est sûr
c'est que vous saurez pourquoi vous ne
serez pas la semaine prochaine
attention on va faire un chip ou jean
marc jean marc ledoux
c'est le nombre de râteaux qu'il a mis à
shy'm sur danse avec les stars parce que
c'est pas son délire où c'est la chaîne
sur laquelle on retrouvera bientôt
l'assuré way sur france 2 ça y est il a
quitté donc ça a été le transfert de
l'été jean-marc comment ça s'est passé
tu quittes tf1 ça a été une déflagration
avait toujours comment pas où je
commence on est en plein confinement il
se passe rien à ma vie à part être papa
à plein temps ce qui est merveilleux
merci à tous
il n'y a rien qui se passe on sait pas
ce qui va arriver je reçois un coup de
téléphone qui me vient de alexandre rey
le miel elle me dit mon ami va sur elle
me dit je remarque quand on voit comment
ton avenir en france après dix ans de
danse avec les stars
qu'est ce que tu as envie qu'est-ce qui
se passe
bagis si vous avez quelque chose à
proposer
elle me l'a lu des mots de passe du je
au mieux vers toi dans trois semaines
parce que j'étais ouvert à entendre des
propositions et là elle me parle de
spectaculaire ça m'a pris à peu près je
pense que ç'a pris un grou 10 secondes
10 secondes pour dit oui pour dit oui
c'est ou fait franchement mais c'étaient
des jeunes décision familiale avec ma
femme et la famille que je pouvais plus
faire c'est aller retour la raclée ça
c'est merveilleux mais il fallait que je
passe à d'autres choses et l'opportunité
était trop belle alors ta mission s'est
joué les monsieur loyal d'un show de 12
numéros
au menu des acrobaties des cascades de
la surprise la poésie on va voir un
numéro où on a une vidéo voilà on va
voir déjà les la bande annonce vous
allez voir ce sera le 3 octobre sur
france 2 c'est l'anniversaire de mon
père donc j'espère qu'il a importé
chantier valentin oui les balances mais
c'est pas pour ça qu'ils aiment les
vierges
[Rires]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et il faut y aller ou pas alors jean
marc tu vas regardez-moi je vienne où
pâturent gamme encore wayne juste comme
ça c'est spectaculaire
ouvrez grand vos yeux est ce que tu peux
nous faire c'est quoi ton début
d'émission tu peux pas nous faire pour
les téléspectateurs qui t'arrive tu dis
quoi
je sais pas si je devrais être sage pas
gâcher la surprise
oui on le cache pas là exactement merci
c'est les rebelles que l'otan joue mais
le truc le plus important c'est de
redonner la lumière à ces artistes ces
artistes qui travaillent présentement
malheureusement volonté de chevaux non
mais qui travaillent présentement dans
l'ombre
c'est vrai ces artistes du spectacle
vivant qui ont besoin de retourner dans
cette lumière et faire ce qu'ils font de
mieux faire sourire les gens changer
leur quotidien et le 3 octobre
tout le monde va pouvoir être là
regardez dans le confort ça mais moi
j'ai envie de le voir en animateur de ce
chien a eu vraiment pas j'en ai vu
quelque chose de très bizarre c'est quoi
parce que on a tracé pendant deux jours
parce que si à la base déjà c'est un
pari la mini 12 performance dans le
studio 217 avec l'aco ville et toutes
les mesures de protection quand on doit
les sanitaires
pour moi c'est un pari gagné
une promesse qui je l'espère va être la
plus belle promesse de la rentrée eh ben
on espère on suivra ça de 3 octobre
contre de la vie
chiffre 2 2 powell zen est ce que c'est
la news son premier titre sort sur
youtube
2000 2010 9,2 en 2019 et non pas l'année
2019 c'est l'année où son premier titre
sort sur youtube ou l'année où elle sort
son premier titre de rap sur le nom
watch des wesh la tristesse elle un
succès fulgurant en 2019 t repéré sur un
star par ton futur manager feneu wii qui
est exceptionnel c'est un grand
producteur
voilà il produit le mois suivant ton
premier single qui s'appelle jaton ouais
et là c'est peut-être ma reconnaissance
à tulle quittera jamais jamais hicham un
nabot sabots attention
le chiffre 4 pour jean-marc alors disent
bonjour martine et aux 6,7 nombre de
saisons il apparaît dans danse avec les
stars c'est le nombre de fois on lui a
fait la bad et jean marc généreux cité
généreux donne dix balles et a fait
quatre saisons de danse avec les stars
dis moi la vérité j'ai une info tu me
dire si c'est vrai l'asie est ce que
c'est vrai qu'à un moment tf1 et ont dit
d'arrêter de dire que j'achète la
production la chaîne n'a jamais empêché
de dire quoi que ce soit c'est sûr que
[Musique]
non mais j'ai bientôt un moment il te
dit
mollo sur les j'achète non non non il
n'y avait pas de mollo son désir au
chocolat sont les chercher jusqu'à amant
bonne année pour moi ouais je peux pas
être monsieur j'achète toute ma vie
d'accord je suis monsieur je vends
calcul est d'accord donc la recherche
est c'est fini tu diras pas c'est un
dictionnaire je peux l'utiliser
n'importe quand j'achète je vais quel
bar il faut bien qu'ils achètent des
tractations qui est vrai et ce break
qu'il a déposée j'achète
oui atteint déposé chacun apporte ses
fesses 6 1 c'est en ça rapporte
non c'était pas pour faire de l'argent
c'était pour le protéger parce que je
voulais pas qu un moment donné quelqu'un
utilise et sage est à mauvais escient
alors nous on dit j'achète en son nom on
est réprimandé parce que j'ai des
billets 2 euros lui la dépose les
achètent
et bernard montiel valeur toi et moi
j'ai déposé je vaux pour moi je gagne 59
c'est le nombre de camions ça qu'elle a
reçus depuis son titre à nice à c'est en
millions le nombre de vues sur youtube
pour aller dit c'est un truc de ouf et
anissa c'est que c'est une vraie
histoire on pas quoi c'est vraiment un
mec qui t'arrive tabac j'ai tout de
suite mais ça raconte quoi quoi y'a
vraiment un mec qui t'a tromper mais là
pas de valeur avec ça c'est sympa de
principe non mais c'est fou ça t'as
vraiment grand frère non il vient de
thaler vraiment confiance à grands frais
en état des frères et soeurs oui j'ai
une grande terre et ça c'est vraiment ta
cousine non pas à nice ah mais oui mais
s'ils ouvrent cette histoire en est
quitte à tromper la qui a fait ça là
haut
mais quel est ce qu'une seule à la
lourde ouest et il ya surtout le monde
est revenue sur tu hors de ma vue
c'est vrai que tu as we avait vraiment
écrit ça au départ ouais mais j'ai pas
fait exprès mais tu sais que tout le
monde dit ça maintenant c'est une
novlangue l un à l avant comme annoncé
sa trémie mais faudrait pousser pas
français moi j'aime voir son pote et moi
signe parce que je viens d'arriver
pour les autres ici qui sont voilà les
auteurs de délits c'est un peu la langue
oui moi je me trouve ça passe tu hors de
ma vue j'ai eu tout à fait une photo
avec kaya nakamura qu'on aime beaucoup
aussi
vous êtes les deux stars en ce moment de
number one vous entendez bien maigre
elle a pas de rivalité entre sa médaille
non c'est toi vous allez faire un duo
pareil à un point ça s'appelle lots
papymik et passe à taper sur la nissan
avais tu m'as fait chaud ce qui permets
tu m'as p congo
c'est là qu'à moi aussi je le dis
souvent très grande artiste ayala kaboré
et je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui la critiquent mais je peux vous dire
que ce qu'elle fait c'est exceptionnel
et ce sur des jalousies mascali est très
très fort allez on fait une dernière
pour jean-marc jean mas jean marc jean
marc jean marc ela
ah oui 9-9-9 c'est l'âge de l'âge l'âge
hors de ma vie où il a rencontré sa
femme ont le nombre de torsion
testiculaire tortue rencontre tension
torsion j'ai rencontré ma femme
et oui 9,59 les chéris hewitt a
rencontré sa femme à 9 ans oui mais ça
serait que de nous elle s'appelle anissa
non non non parce que j'aurais proposé
n'a trempé
bah ouais nan bétail aux mecquois et
donc j'étais dans la même classe c était
mon ami et quand j'ai rencontré petit
saint emilion croiser les yeux de france
moussouris bon ma vie a changé quoi mais
depuis depuis que tu as l'âge de 9 ans
oui quoi tu pense à elles et à quel âge
d'or où les gens voir ça avec là je
t'oublie tournage voilà on va dire oui
mais ça fait c'est fait comme le temps
vous êtes ensemble ça fait très
longtemps
[Rires]
c'est quoi sur et non mais c'est ouf
et vous avez fait de la danse ensemble
oui ta danse de salon elle tous les
samedis elle partait à l'école de danse
aujourd'hui on à l'école dimanche
l'église il restait juste le samedi ah
ouais donc pour conquérir son coeur je
te lis prend des cours de danse et je
suis ici ça c'est qu'il faut jamais
jamais dans ma vie j'aurais rêvé de
faire la danse est bas mais là dans ce
deuxième coup de foudre
c'est un premier coup de foudre r femmes
deuxième coup de foudre la danse
troisième coup de fouet est acculée avec
scapulaire
[Applaudissements]